[Music]
Atropa belladonna will kill you datura
will put you to sleep forever
I can item will kill you Lana will
produce cyanide and kill you
every plant tear in the poison garden is
poisonous and has the ability to kill
you my name's Trevor Jones
I'm the head gardener of Annika garden
this plant is giant hogweed it will get
up to around about eight foot high it's
photo toxic so will burn your skin and
give you blisters for up to seven years
this garden is set in the wall garden of
the old castle in Northumberland UK
which have learned about 95 plants and
we're adding to the collection of all
the time this plant is a can item or
monkshood wonderful blue flowers at the
hole of the plant is poisonous the
berries crushed up and fed to you will
kill you
the leaves themselves will kill you also
as will the root and the stem we have to
obviously maintain the garden so we have
to tend the plants and when we do that
we have to be very careful of the way we
operate so we have to cover some of our
skin when we deal with particularly
dangerous plants this plant is log it
produces cyanide and we all know what
that will do to you so it was the
brainchild of the Duchess Duchess of
Northumberland so rather than having a
herb garden she decided to create more
interest and have a poison garden there
are very very common plants in fact a
lot of them are caught we call cottage
garden plants and they're grown in many
people's gardens but people don't know
how hard for they actually are this is
Atropa belladonna for berries are enough
to kill a child people are intrigued by
poisonous plants and often very worried
when they come out because many of them
will be growing these plants at home but
they don't realize the powerful impact
plants can have on us as humans
definitely it's a good way to get rid of
your life
[Laughter]
you